hey what's happening thanks for turning
into another episode of left to be talk
this episode is brought to you by my
fantastic sponsor el cajon Harley if you
need a motorcycle don't go anywhere else
go to El Cajon Harley I don't care what
state you live in or country hit them in
Southern California fantastic dealer how
cool is that sponsoring the podcast
nobody cooler than that outside the box
going yet we want to be we want to be a
cool dealer check them out El Cajon
harley-davidson they got the brand new
Milwaukee a touring models in there I
wrote it this thing burns rubber man
excellent new murder by Harley hitting a
home run with that thing they also got a
killer service department they can get
your finance man you're thinking maybe
you got bad credit or something go sim
man I got financed and look at me I'm
gangster anyway el cajon Harley they got
a motocross helmets all kinds of stuff
go see my boy Greg rather valo amana
volume and value oh man follow them on
twitter instagram and facebook and go
see him el cajon harlem all right let's
get into the show great guest today
introduced yourself hey buddy it's matt
braunger hi everybody how I but I'm good
man thanks her I'm in the show oh yeah
I've been trying to have you out for a
while but we're both [ __ ] in and out
of town on all the time that's the
problem with doing French podcast is
just like yeah we all live here but we
don't live here that much I know where
you been recently oh let's see you most
I was in I was in Brooklyn I hit a
couple places in New Jersey um and yeah
I mean I'm just about to go to Denver in
Dallas so where's on Comedy Works no I'm
doing I'm doing like this this beer
festival with a beth stelling we're do
like a one-nighter that a friend of
mine's a promoter out there and yeah
yeah got me a great deal and um and then
just going to play hyenas in dallas and
i played there before I haven't either
oh god you how are you been doing comedy
about 16 years Wow and when he's from
Portland Oregon originally a great city
yeah started doing comedy Chicago though
Oh what so what got you to Chicago uh
was I just went there right after
college cuz I had I was pissed I was
like I was back on as a pretentious
actor type and my friends were out there
acting in like black box theaters and
we're just come on and that was kind of
like you're working man actor city I was
like I want to do that and p.m. you know
what's cool in New York and if I want to
be super poor super poor yeah I beyond
beyond poor yeah yeah and I fell into
the improv scene from that and then went
in to stand up from there you know and
started out with you know Kyle Kinane
Pete Holmes Camille no Johnny and
Hannibal in the gang so like wow what a
[ __ ] crude and we were like that I
mean I look back it's like now it's it's
like x-men origins like not necessarily
for me but for a lot of us where it's
just like so UT i don't even know you
know what I mean we had no idea that we
were gonna I don't know so many of us
from make it so big yeah you know well
the guys you dis described the thing I
love about each one of them is they're
completely original including yourself
Thanks it's not like you know it sound
like oh that's the grunge era you know
right or the same outfits and stuff you
had a min yeah completely truly is um so
all those guys are in that long on 17
years not necessarily as long I mean
they were like you know like Hannibal's
younger than us TJ Miller was younger
than us look at this I'm like yeah I
mean it was it was still from you know
the same again I could go on like john
roy named Greg John right good friend
not a lot of people um I mean I just
it's it was kind of this yeah weird ass
little scene yeah that's incredible hmm
now I've had some things come up over
the weekend and it's good to talk to
somebody because I don't have too many
comedians on I only like to have
comedians on that you know like like I I
bond with you know to me oh yeah I'm not
just gonna have a guy on like hey so
what are you about everybody does know I
feel dude because like you know I've
just started having I'm a podcast called
ding dong er with matt braunger where I
basically like hitchhike into your life
for like half an hour then I get out
it's like a crazy guy just jumping into
your car here hiking that's why I listen
to podcast like in the car plane like
you know so I just like let me jump in
your life and so now I'm having friends
on but I'm just having friends
yeah but I mean yeah I don't none of us
want to be an interviewer it's not a
promo machine thing it's just people
that I look up to and and and also i'm
very interested in those guys including
yourself that y'all mentioned those are
styles of comedy that are way outside
the box they're not really i don't
really as i get into it i'm coming up on
7 years here next month and i'm doing
great for seven years man that's awesome
I the thing is I hit a couple things
this weekend and it's great that you're
a guest today because I can talk to you
about it while we're on the show one of
them was do you remember a nightmare we
can you had as far as like crowds yes
yeah where was it the the very first the
very first road gig I ever got oh yeah
ever got ah Mick Betancourt who was kind
of like our kind of like Godfather back
then like around her say mates with him
he'd been doing comedy longer yeah and
he was also just at the time a stone
maniac like now he's now he's like sober
and he like rights hour-long dramas yeah
I mean he worked on SVU for the longest
knowledge it's his career is amazing to
me but he you know I was waiting tables
and he was like hey he was the first guy
said to me hey you can make a living at
this someday and I was like wow and then
be at some point he just went like um
i'm doing i got this gig this weekend
both the headliner and the feature
dropped out do you want to feature for
me and I'm like yeah yeah let's do it
yeah and I didn't even enter mice my
mind that it was the weekend after
September 11 2000 oh didn't enter my
mind Wow like I'd pretty much just
started I've been doing it maybe a year
and a half two years yeah and like it
didn't I was so clueless it's that thing
where I mean I'm one of those people who
I don't see the forest for the trees so
many times absolutely I'm just you know
you consider everything but the most
important thing yeah I should be
spending people looking for comedy right
yeah like no and we played this place
what in this area called the tri-county
area in Illinois that it was a comedy
club and then it turned to a dance club
afterwards like the fog machines would
be hooked up like while you're still up
people intermixing yeah well and and I
just remember every night I mean that
was the first time I ever had one of
those moments on stage where you just
drop your [ __ ] and get real for a
second yeah yeah cuz i remembers just
saying like just do you know for jokes
in a row just ate it and then it's going
hey guys I all I feel like doing is
crying too yeah let's be honest I mean
yeah you know now what what what made it
bad because my question is so broad and
because I there's so many different
Bad's there's bad crowd there's your
shits not work sure a bad crop sound bad
uh yeah bad broker or owner all this
different stuff but what made this bad
well it's interesting cuz you know all
the guys I kind of started out with like
Kyle and I were kind of like brothers in
arms we're the ones who go to all the
shows together and like we started out
like riding around the same time and our
stuff like we would laugh at like really
really weird stuff now that's considered
regular common yeah the stuff that is
just like a dark day you're talking
about stuff from your perspective tell
from your life your voice that it takes
someone you know like a not necessarily
but faith but you gotta really you know
want to look at things through someone
else's eyes which is really all I look
for in comedy I like I want to see it
through like you're doing a thing I want
to hear the story on it you're going on
but this was at a time where none of us
would ever we do guest sets it like
zanies which is the only comedy club
around and would never do that well
right you know and so like you know
keeps you going from that are you just
kind of like you're not doing well
because the materials not general broad
hacky sack it's hard and we're also like
young and start now you know and but i
will say look when we play like you know
a non-traditional venue like jose on
weed street or place called quenchers or
whatever hijacked vineyard gosh oh we do
really well because people were really
into like oh they're like oh when I
think a comedy I think of this guy who
talked about how much he hates his wife
yeah this oh this is good this is what I
like you know there yeah yeah
yeah yeah so it was it took a while for
people to kind of be you know into that
comedy in comedy clubs kind of like feel
like like right now it's kind of a
golden age because you can you know no
one thinks of Patton Oswalt is like a
no-call definitely think just does well
wherever you're signing and do that
right he just he never did different
[ __ ] in chuckle hut or you know at this
dis the bookstore he would do a tight
seven in or whatever you know Kyle thing
yeah so so you're up there and it's
going bad has it gone bad every night or
yeah i mean i would get little apps here
and there yeah and what's the headliner
saying is he happy because he can come
out and smash no cuz no cuz that Mick
was a headliner man brought me with you
and Mick would do good but not like he
would do like let's say feature good he
wouldn't do like headliner good right
and it was I really wasn't his fault cuz
he had really good stuff but it was just
such a badly run it the place got shut
down literally two weeks later cuz
somebody got stabbed in the dance floor
like literally yeah the problem I had
and I'm starting to headline a lot now
because I unfortunately um which is
something I never like to say but I need
the money yeah there's no money in
featuring oh yeah and also there was no
future spots anymore mmm I they were
just drying up you know a lot of guy
guys I worked with got TV shows and they
were going out anymore and then
headliners tend to have their two three
guys and then that's it and it's also
hard to you know I'm like not I'm about
I would say medium barrel headliner unit
immediate right in the grand scheme yeah
yeah I can't bring guys right some clubs
I can have a lot of clubs I can't yeah
so you kind of just go all right who you
got whoever you guys want to you know
give me good that's just like another
thing you your agent has to negotiate
with the club yeah you like yeah you can
bring somebody but it's gonna it's gonna
cut into his dough yeah his hotel and
everything real time you're going to
make and you know six dollars to two
dollars and you're gonna [ __ ] right that
the thing is
psych and and I'm I'm ready to man up
and [ __ ] learn the game earned the
process sure but an hour is uh you know
when you've been featuring for like
three years like me and you're out doing
25 with no check dropping stuff you just
come up with the [ __ ] and far on the
good old check drop yeah yeah I got I
had the weirdest thing like you're a
store guy like me and I gotta check drop
during my set I'm like how the [ __ ]
tonight it was like for some reason a
bunch of people and it was Ray was that
thing when it hits to be like little
after midnight were like you're funny
but I gotta go yeah a 9000 s [ __ ] and
it was that thing where I was like how
the UH and it it was literally after the
person before me got off they all called
for their checks yeah they're getting
them yeah middle way through my 20
minutes you know my little 20 minutes in
this out ah what can't escape the check
drop is it there's an evil spot in that
in that Club of that and what it's great
up to that and then the people clear out
and then it's great again cuz you got
the scrag leurs you can really just work
on you [ __ ] and stuff yeah so there's
two different greats you know it's empty
and they're like all right I can get
some [ __ ] done in here but I think that
what one of the problems also is when I
started coming up on 7 years ago now the
store was terrible so when you went on
the road it was [ __ ] great you're
like all right yeah people but now the
store is so great and the crowds are
really comic fan comedy fans that when
you go on the road now and you're
dealing with papered rooms and all that
[ __ ] you're going [ __ ] I gotta get back
home man to the store where it used to
be the opposite so now I just look at it
as like [ __ ] of my podcast could just
make some money I could stay home and
dude the comedy for what I love to do it
for the art of it mm-hmm not I you know
I never got into comedy to make money
sure you know there's people making
[ __ ] millions out there yeah I get it
but to me we
he is about the [ __ ] the process and
getting on and doing the [ __ ] you know
so I'm out there and you know of course
these crowds man the late crowds were
just [ __ ] drunk yeah Eddie late
crowds are tough yeah especially like I
was I was in Atlanta a couple years ago
and like the Late Show and a saturday i
was just like like half the crowd was
fine yeah the other half it seemed like
they'd been doused in bourbon yeah house
and they were all interspersed yeah it
was a liquor section just pockets of
garbage boy just pockets of garbage that
is that is you when we call putting out
fires more girls putting out fires like
I hope for like an hour and it's just
like yeah holy [ __ ] I called him a jet
liners after it happened it may just
laughing like oh yeah yeah oh yeah
Saturday night ten o'clock show the suck
you know I know that and of course you
know your dream is to get to a cathedral
status right to where you just popping
in and it's your audience and shut off
and you know you're also dealing with
different features and stuff that you
and and and host that you get that that
could set up the dynamic all wrong like
the host isn't going a look no talking
during the sad since I gotta testify
they just up there doing this [ __ ] they
don't care and they throw you to the
Wolves see you now and the thing is
you're you're and this is a good as well
as a negative thing you're an interloper
so you're the thing is the great thing
is you're gone out so come Sunday
they're gone yeah you know good or bad
yeah and sometimes it's like oh it's so
good I wish there was another show or
well I comedy morning dad I'm like 24
shows please Jesus yeah comedy works
Acme in Minneapolis company on state and
uh uh uh God Madison Wisconsin yes stand
you know the store the seller yeah ah
[ __ ] it yeah there's all these great
rooms and you'll have people later like
stedelijk surprise like you'll do a late
show sometimes be like that was amazing
yeah you know oh you know I've got the
addict in bloom in Bloomington yeah it's
like boom every single he'll sign it for
like six months a year now well I mean
over the last couple years here and
there but sure but now steadily and
all been pretty [ __ ] good maybe one
or two like garbage can people and I
just go start him in a month yeah but
this was like the sunday show I couldn't
believe what's going on there like oh we
got a group of 40 coming and they they
work at the billiards place and their
boss is bringing them oh these people
were just [ __ ] garbage humans they
weren't even there for comedy I'm like
why are you here yeah well those the
people that aren't even drinking for fun
they're drinking to just just wash it
all away just for you to forget taking
to you know like a marathon drink
drinker that's just like I just want to
drink through my feelings yep and they
get there and then just like oh I gotta
listen to Sky talk now I want to talk
like a baby especially the girls that
are like no one's looking at me I like
you know and it's like it's a girl who
like the girl on the the thing I feels I
could throw the thing with like
bachelorette parties it's always the one
that's like no but I'm like the funny
one yeah I want to say stuff Oh realize
I could think they think this just like
you know and it's bachelor parties too
but it's just like the person who thinks
they're the funny one maybe they are
it's always the construction dude watch
this one man yeah like watches I'll
throw some in the mix here Deborah don't
yell like a catchphrase yeah yeah an ad
yeah yeah that makes you laugh man i
know right then they'll just be like or
they're repeating my bit nuts to birds
haha yeah oh yeah in their mind that's
the most dangerous heckler that one that
thinks they're helping yeah they really
do that is worst in a lot of ways and no
person who's like you suck yeah you can
just destroy that person without any any
need to look at your conscience yeah you
asked for it you know rough out there do
you ever get out there and you're like
man [ __ ] this oh no in the end no
because because look it's a be one thing
I'll never forget and I bring this guy
up sometimes and I talked to like uh you
know comics were just like I don't know
man and it's been driving me crazy I
remember doing I did a guest set for
this dude I think I yeah I still lived
in Chicago or maybe I was featuring and
I was still living here anyway uh cuz i
didn't i didn't start headlining to like
probably two thousand seven or eight
when i was already out here you know
right not in chicago you're just
featuring the whole time
oh and hosting like you know playing
little weird rooms and stuff but this
guy he gets on stage and everything he
did just crushed right because he was
and he was talking about you know stuff
with his wife and all this stuff but you
could tell like oh you've done every one
of these bits a billion times no I think
it's off stage and the guy was I could
see it he was like shaking his hands are
shaking a little bit and he's like
talking to me it was like one like
seeing like someone going through like
the DTS I knew it wasn't that yeah it
was just wear and tear from the road
he's Torah he was talking he's like he's
like so how long you been doing it I'm
like I don't know like three four years
I cool woman doing it like and he said
this really long time and he just and
I'm in my head I was like I can I can't
let myself be this guy yeah where who
knows maybe he's on his third marriage
yeah and you know alimony he's paying
all this stuff and not riding can't he
can't no not right I riding he's afraid
to write right because if he starts you
know eating [ __ ] or where I'll get hired
won't get hired a guy and he's like on
the edge he's probably taken justly know
the the smallest check they give a
headline or whatever and it was just
that it's yeah so it's like as long as
I'm not long as I fill my life with
enough other stuff to keep me busy yeah
that's also come comedy based whether
it's writing in podcast yes yes is any
up and not having that mentality of of
of you know the climate of fear yeah
where it's kind of like got the extreme
version would be I love to help Patrice
O'Neal would be like he's like when if a
crowd would turn him like oh you're not
gonna make it bad for me I'm gonna make
it bad for you yeah you just say his
most brutal [ __ ] yeah the room yeah yeah
I don't have that kind of harm whether
it's strong but I amazing yeah and so
it's kind of like you know um I just the
thing about comedies it takes a long
time to get really good at it especially
stand up and also just like anything is
worth doing you got to love it yeah I
don't love it why are you doing oh yeah
I got that yeah yeah you can that you
can tell somebody that's like up on
stage and just phoning it in yeah you
know they're just like trotting out the
same [ __ ] there was a guy I remember who
hosted this show I did think it was in
Raleigh North Carolina and um he he was
great but I was like this guy's really
funny and all the all the
waiters and waitresses were like well
yeah he's been doing those jokes for
like 15 years yeah and they're like
daytime when to go like oh I can he's
gonna be up there exactly 50 they're
also in the back repeating his bed down
am I crazy glue uh-huh they look at each
other like they want to shoot each other
yeah it's a comedy is like um you know
or it's like an addiction for me
absolutely love great yeah and now I'm
starting to realize that some of my
voice isn't gonna work in a paper room
you understand you don't mean so like
when I'm performing around here people a
lot of people know who I am or whatever
from the podcast and stuff sure and then
they're there into the these the style
of bits yeah and then when you get out
in the road you're gonna have these
pockets of your podcast guest or friends
fans hmm and then you're gonna have
papered room and they're just kind of
like where's yes yes you know what I
mean I would say just make fun of that
yeah just be you know yeah yeah I mean
it you'd be amazed at how much people
love when you just rip on him oh no like
I know you guys just came cuz why he was
something on the street outside of your
lies see that's what a sunday show
wanted yeah they want cuz I I felt it I
ripped on the girl she thought she was
the hot one in the crowd and I go I get
it I know you are working the one
everyone hates know like yeah yeah get
her yeah yeah I was like no I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna do that for you I'm
out here trying to work in an hour
mm-hmm uh you know work new stupid [ __ ]
yeah sunday i did something I've never
done in comedy ever I stood up there
delivered the bits and just plowed
through and walked off yeah yeah just
like any time she would try to get
something out i would just be in the
next bit already that i've done that was
like nope nope i'm just gonna talk over
you yeah that's because when you comes
down to it no one can hear you but the
people right around you I can hear you
yeah cuz your passes are all facing
totally but yeah I mean it someone
really has to be like a committed
disruptor to have to you know be able to
resist that onslaught yeah otherwise
you're like look I
have the boomstick yeah every week I was
winning and then she explodes in the
club manager because of the two drink
minimum and everything at the end of the
night so I was kind of happy the club
manager had to deal with her too because
they didn't throw her out yeah so he was
like well how was that and I was like
the worst yeah like nobody threw her out
I later up three times and yeah I think
that's really crazy I think that's what
gets under my skin a little bit is when
you're the product for the drinks it
doesn't matter when it comes down to it
yeah we really are yep job which is one
of those you know unspoken but real
things but shouldn't be shouldn't be too
real where I go right and it's tough for
comedy clubs to have like a lot of real
security but yeah there I do love the
ones where you can just do the code you
know think that guy needs a cup of
coffee yeah and throw that dude out yeah
yeah yeah exactly oh that's right yeah
that's my flash all good yeah but like
there but like yeah just throw him right
it could but I remember I had a show at
this place called the jukebox comedy
club in Peoria Illinois it's like little
rundown but the guy the guy who runs it
loves comedy it's a legendary comedy
club been around for a god like
something like 30 or something crazy pra
mm-hmm that's a Richard Pryor light it
is it is and they have a really bad
statue of them but they had a statue of
oh yeah nice but uh yeah you go I what
walked over to it was like oh guys you
know and it's funny cuz I my job all
right and some are great like Lenny one
right now at the rainbow is face I'm an
amazing yeah yeah uh but this I had this
bachelor party of real young dudes that
kept fun they're all like arms crossed
yeah and they kept piping up and like
everyone else is loving my [ __ ] and it
wasn't even the biggest crowd and kept
by and I finally did I just snapped you
guys like I was like look man you guys
got us be [ __ ] men and shut the [ __ ]
up yeah you know cuz like I was like
it's enough man this isn't funny I'm
making the moment real weird for
everyone yes of you yeah and I was like
just like I mean could hear heard a pin
drop yeah yeah like seven seconds I got
myself together went back at my jokes
finish strong you know I like another 20
minutes good night went back in the
green room and I'm just pacing because
I'm like I'm mad at myself I feel weak I
lost it yep but then I went out to the
bar and I was like I was that one of
those weekends where I was just like I'm
not even a drink and I went to the barn
I didn't go get house but I definitely
got a [ __ ] frosty mug yeah and had
that and I dude comes up like the
biggest one from the bachelor party was
like hey man just want to say thanks my
buddies who wouldn't shut up for the
[ __ ] worst yeah thanks for handling
that and I was like all right yeah
thanks giant 22 year old the I am I head
in yeah no but it was that thing it was
like oh oh oh I did the right thing yeah
all right thinking like one by one
people from the audience who were just
hanging out in the bar we're coming up
hey thanks yeah they like you know
whispering they have we came all the way
to see you man oh yeah so I know
sometimes you just you you know it's
hard to have perspective and go like oh
you know I yeah uh I can't I can't lose
it on these people but sometimes I mean
I have friends who like I'm a friendly
dude all all shine someone on to make
fun of them and go you know I I'll take
it from here yeah I'm socking yep but I
have friends who the moment someone
talks they're like it no shut the [ __ ]
up yeah you're making yourself look
stupid stop oh yeah I know guys like
that and when I started comedy I was
like well I'd never do that and then
there was doing it five years later up
it's pretty good there's no I don't
think that I I I love learning this
stuff from comedy I'm love you know like
you know I've done over 3,000 shows and
I was talking about monday on the
episode and you know you think you've
seen it all right yeah I got man I've
seen it all but when you have a whole
room that is just wasted the problem was
the club I was in there their bars all
around the club so if ten o'clock show
they're drinking at the other bars till
the ten o'clock show at the time I'm on
it's 1045 they've had few more in the
club and this whole [ __ ] room was
like a bomb went off oh yeah and I just
stepped up I was like wow and the
feature kept saying from the stage good
luck with this one Dean good luck with
these guys and I was
man this is gonna be [ __ ] brutal yeah
I had a UH played a club and I had for
bachelorette parties neo and the manager
was backstage like a perplexing like an
apology like I can't throw them all out
I'm sorry yeah I'm sorry and they were
all out of hand yeah and the comic
before me did like okay but then you
know I did well because I kind of played
around and then got into my bits and I
end it ended up giving me like one of my
favorite bits from like four or five
years ago like I just told the story of
that night a little bit and it ended up
being fine yeah there are those times we
just like well [ __ ] it like uh yeah I'm
a firefighter sometimes the house just
has a you know a tree on fire sound just
the whole [ __ ] thing I'm gonna run in
and save a baby well I can't not run in
yeah I mean you don't have none of us
had a power to be like not do it I'm
skipping this one yeah I like these guys
stories but like huh like Claire Larry
David like in this 78 we just walk out
and just look at the crowd and go now
and leave really no no just like oh yeah
how many Star situa what cybele's like
the audience didn't know what hit him
Wow how dare you yeah just now looking
at them ya know you guys say that's why
he's a [ __ ] billionaire now he's dead
I'm from marginally comedy everybody
loves you know I remember as the the
[ __ ] night went down the managers I
cancer how was it out there as I did it
was you know the worst it was absolutely
the worst since I've been doing comedy
they were sitting up well you know what
uh Steve Martin says he quit comedy cuz
of this late show Friday nights Wow and
I was like why never heard that but I
was like wag I could see that you know
yeah especially I'm not a [ __ ] I'm
ready to take the challenge on but it's
just new to me so I'm just like whoa
whoa also steve martin like when he quit
news like Zeppelin yeah his his late
night Friday nights were like late night
friday there is a staple center yeah I
don't like doing his pits in chamblee
now if everyone's hammered you know in
the Hammersmith ballroom and
like oh god you know like you can walk
it out there like wild and crazy guy the
whole place you're like I'm not [ __ ] you
you could do a joke they don't know yeah
yeah a hitch up later hit play the heads
cashmere in the same way uh but now when
you're starting out comedy who are your
guys who did you like uh well I mean
when I was a kid my parents had a copy
of class clown by George Carlin yeah
great that was that's still one of my
favorite comedy I love it and obviously
prior I I would sneak downstairs and
watch like through through the banister
I'd watch like Sarah I live by my
parents I was secretly hello mom I'm 42
yeah I'm 50 so I watch season one night
wow yeah yeah I know right on I was
addicted to John Belushi ma'am yeah
wouldn't believe him and then standing
Bill Murray you know [ __ ] Caddyshack
all that [ __ ] yeah yeah that whole
national lampoon's school kill and then
like just in through like when I was of
it coming of age like high school like
Phil Hartman watch it like him and sent
it live just like insanely funny
original all comic yeah all right we're
sure tell sure ah but then you know uh
you get older and you'd have like uh
Richard Pryor was eternal of course but
you'd have like Mitch Hedberg and um you
know when Chris Rock did bring the pain
was just like I don't even know how he
see change gears and became the funniest
person living yeah man and from that
point I remember it just becoming this
there were new new people uh that I
discovered like Brian Regan yeah you
know and acclaim guys guys that were
clean unnecessarily no I mean it's I
like people that are really unique like
right now I don't think there's anyone
as as as amazing as Maria Bamford rahu
it's just like who's like a wizard like
when she just goes in and out of these
characters and some believe they know
from my life yeah that it almost scares
me yeah but it's not just mimicry it's
also like oh you're this is a real
moment in your life kind of thing I I
can see her man
when I whenever I can I'll see she's
around town and I go and I don't even
talk to I just go to the back of the
room sit solo and watch the show hmm
because it's like performance art man ya
butt but like in like if someone's doing
performance art and magic yeah and
acrobatics yeah yeah yeah and it's just
so it's just so it's hard to be original
in this game because what I loved about
her was Oh impressions but they're not
[ __ ] jack nicholson [ __ ] Arnold
Schwarzenegger and center yeah it's uh
someone she just met its and I'm where I
feel like I'm in the living room when
she's like oh hey yeah you read a camera
you know she's doing these things you
know this is the only problem with me is
I've got bad hearing so I'm always like
what's she saying there you know right i
need i need those movie headphones you
know this movie kiss man i swear my
urine it's [ __ ] shot man i saw a guy
when I was in college we would just do
this thing for class which is like
performance evaluation where you just go
to see the weirdest art yeah onstage and
just like would write like papers about
it and like so this guy named Issei
ogata who's a Japanese comedian they
calm like the Robin Williams of Japan
but his whole thing is he makes fun of
the status quo so a lot of people are
like he's undermining us he's against
Japan and it's always authority figures
yeah and so he'll do like the gruff
voiced a Japanese guy he'll do like the
guy with a shitty job who just wants to
be happy and stuff and I had a thing and
we all had things in our ears where I
guys translating everything he said oh
wow and it was [ __ ] hilarious yeah
well it's like I I was knocked out by
that but you're like you know how you if
you're gonna be funny and in like any
language yeah kind of thing and he does
characters so it's a little different
than someone doing stand-up right right
right you know it's like it just goes
back to that relatability thing we had a
thinking a guy in Chicago um who's still
out there named Dwayne Kennedy who we
all looked up to me Kyle kamael uh CJ
Sullivan PAP rice you named it all of us
were like that's the guy cuz he was a
guy who you know could have been as big
as he ever wanted to be and now he's
like he's got an album out and he's
trying to be a
more you know forward with it and stop
right right see like one of those guys
it's just like hey they'll come to me
like he doesn't social media and all
like that he was just like I just want
to chill out and like I remember being
backstage I zanies being like man cuz we
were there's a Chicago comedy festival
we were all in that was kind of like a
grassroots festival and I was meeting
industry for the first time I was like
man I sure would love to get like a
development deal at heard those are nice
and Dwayne's like man I've had like five
they're all right I was like five I
who's had that you know yeah he's all
he'd already been on Letterman like
three times that Letterman who would be
sitting there with a glass of red wine
what set anyone nude much yet much of a
drinker yes habit cuz his stuff was so
um uh uh he had this cool accent that
like he could just say this stuff about
like race relations that was biting yeah
but amazing yeah you know yeah like
that's the thing it's it's too I think
that the thing I need to try to dig and
do next is make the material smarter you
know my god love Bill Hicks where he
says played to the highest IQ in the
room you know yeah I can see that but
also I would also say but at the same
time be true to yourself oh yeah no no
total no totally uh I'm not calling you
stupid yeah yeah now we turn yourself
man come its fight alone whatever else
and know your prob teacher plated at the
height of your intelligence guy yeah
yeah chef for you Russell yeah except
for you yeah there's no hope but what
I'm what I'm saying is if you're um like
I'm really loving Stanhope in the last
couple years easy to me he's kind of
like the Henry Rollins have stand up
yeah like Rollins is just so you know
he's not a comic but his spoken word is
making me laugh the whole time because
he's opening your eyes cuz it's ditch
truth it's all true ariana true you know
raw truth is often it can be painful or
can off it can be just as often
hilarious hey don't just makes me think
of the guy I can't believe it like he's
a he's a he's like an astrophysicist
poet in a bar hammered and he's just
saying [ __ ] to you that you're like
you're crying laughing you're like gotik
I'm glad we're not around a lot of
people would be offended by that yeah
but it's like really
honest and real and there's no Kowski of
comedy you know II mean yeah but what
also doesn't you know the thing about
Bukowski was like he was he's definitely
in love with being famous and was like
I'm pretty he'd be the guy like how
anchorman let you know all right he was
like yeah I'm kind of a big deal yeah I
could see Bukowski saying is kind of a
big deal to like a chick in a bar
Stanhope no no no no pal just had it has
like no ego yeah and just but like you
know he really he loves comedy and loves
comedians yeah and you know it's amazing
because i really like i love to dig into
dudes and watch their stuff from the
early days like I'm a huge CK fan of
course Marin and and burn and stuff and
it's really amazing how these people
change over the time and finally find
they've their voice you know what I mean
that's pretty well because I haven't
seen any stand up step from say 15 16 18
years ago and I was wondering what he
started out like now when you started
out were you totally different than now
were you just doing jokes I just
remember an old Stanhope it was like his
first TV appearance and he was just like
I think was in LA he's like hey just FYI
do you guys go down the sewer grate
outside and go through go through all
the all the the feces and everything
down there there's an area in an alcove
down under there uh right next to a dead
guy there's a place you can smoke like
he's making fun of like yeah yeah oh can
he worry yeah yeah yeah just like a
public service now the first thing I'm
reading his book right now it's
incredible but his mom yeah dot well
it's free yeah yeah it's it I mean
they're not just about his mom right
right right yeah the opening part but
that you know that reminds me of his
first not his first his special from
last year oh yeah where it opens up the
first bid is about his mom and I was
like I've never seen anybody be this
dangerous on a special opening with a
bit about we're gonna kill my mom helped
her kill herself yeah and then it turns
out to be a joke about so I'm not giving
it away but about something else and
you're just like this is anime imeem to
go all the
that way yeah further where the joke
ends is incredible yeah yeah so you're
early stuff were you like just cuz I
think back now of course when I started
you just want the laughs yeah I'm so I
didn't have any kind of like oh I gotta
speak truth to power man I just all I
just wanted to be it's funny yeah that's
really like all I want now to but uh you
know in the past no years I've
definitely tried to dig down and say it
wouldn't let me find some horrible [ __ ]
yeah and be a little more real yeah you
know here and there I don't know way I'm
doing a bit about diabetes right now I
got diabetes now and uh uh and it just
stops the room ah it's I'm gonna go feel
bad for you yeah it's it's it's from
it's from a kind place right but you're
also being like no but you're not being
kind yeah you're not helping me yeah you
gotta understand yeah I'm [ __ ] not
dead it's okay to laugh I don't have
cancer yeah I wouldn't say it yeah I
want you to laugh absolutely yeah yeah
yeah so I've had to pepper with some
some bits inside of there yeah and now
it's starting to work hmm and I was
telling burr this I was out with him a
couple weeks ago and I was like I feel
like my three new bits and this is
really a strange place to be in are so
real that the old bits I just don't even
I don't even like talk Calvin now right
you just but that that's just you guys
got to learn to navigate yeah you know
you can kind of go like oh let's go real
and then throw that away and then go
into yeah you know whatever your silly
bit you really like like I will I will
like there's one or two jokes I'll be
like and it'll get a laughing I'll be
like that's my dumbest joke thank you
anything like that good it's like I know
it's stupid yeah you know but it says
it's fun and so like you that's a great
thing when you have like you know a
little bit of confidence and your
confidence in yourself you can all even
go like look I'm doing this joke cuz i
love it yeah I know it won't do that
great yep yeah yeah that's right i was
saying that one's for me yes yeah in
fact I'd okay yeah it's funny because i
think it was patent or somebody early on
i read this thing i read [ __ ] loads of
stuff about comedy cuz I just I just
[ __ ] love it I read this thing where
it might have been a tell or somebody
but they said don't have your whole set
edgy egg then there's no way anybody
there's no way it's just like we get it
yeah then usko [ __ ] your brother and
then you go into the next bit about how
you killed your sister well after why
users all right right right you know you
have one really edgy bit and then that's
the one maybe you leave on where people
go kill that was correct yeah no yeah oh
yeah I would agree with that and you
want to have you know textures and
things yeah you want to have like
different layers to yourself too so it's
not just here comes the [ __ ] yeah in
a biker comic or whatever yeah like one
of the genius things about Dave
Chappelle is that he like a hot man he
like heaps he sounds like every joke
sounds like he just thought of it I know
and he might have you know i know that's
what's kind of been even there and
that's coming from us who know the biz
inside and out yeah I feel like he's
almost like the David Blaine a comedy
where you're going that's some
next-level magic I think he's like
almost like a you know like an idiot
savant where he's got you know he's so
good at this thing yeah maybe like he
can't uh you know work on microwave like
he knows yeah I mean we don't know yeah
it's that thing where it's like where
someone could there's a guy who can sit
down and beat a computer at chess and he
knows how to do that like you look at
guising to go who books their fights yes
you know yeah like who does it ain't you
Yeah right it's not the simple things
just funny they melt down oh I gotta get
a [ __ ] fly die then they got a genius
record like The Strokes first out me
know your exactly ya like like it's
about schapelle I remember saying like
well any of you like so long ago that he
didn't think comedians have material I
thought you just went up there and talk
yeah I did tunes when I started like I
was watching guys at the Laugh Factory
and I was like I'm getting ready to do
comedy and I was like I'm i know for one
thing for sure when I do it it's gonna
be new stuff every night I seen these
guys it is the same stuff all the time
yeah and then really quickly you realize
oh that's that's not gonna work ya know
we used to try to do we had this thing
it back in Chicago called the Lions Den
that was an open mic every Monday you
never missed it and if you
you have to get there like by six or
seven and they'd like ring a bell and
you'd sign up put your slip in the thing
and if they rang it again you didn't you
didn't get in right but it was like
between 30 and 50 people everyone doing
five minutes and you always try to do
like it was that was one of the things I
missed the most he's like having that
week of going walk out what's my new
five yeah you know what's my hand little
thing yeah yeah that's why I left some
time but like yes yeah me now yeah and I
remember Neil was like you know he's
like there's no excuse that you
shouldn't be able to come up with a new
minute a week that's four minutes a
month yeah then two months you got eight
minutes and then four months you got 16
minutes and when he put it down into
that [ __ ] a small of a timing thing I
was like [ __ ] he's right man and it's
and you think that's easy like I'll come
up with a new minute this week and then
you know that's that's let's burst thing
he's like he's like you're all you got
to do is stitch a new five minutes a
month well I got an hour a year and I
was like oh okay yeah and yeah you know
you you think about it that way it's
like okay that makes more sense yeah I
think yeah but I mean I also you know
like a lot of people you throw [ __ ] away
thank you know you work a joke a bunch
and you go you know I don't love it yeah
I don't love it I took a chunk out of
one of my jokes and the joke is so much
better yeah but it made the joke shorter
Yeah right yeah yeah cuz its parts where
it's too wordy and all that how do you
write do you write on stage yeah I let
me just record it um no I'll just kind
of keep like it'll just kind of keep in
my head uh generally how no bullet
points I can your phone or something
like this let me call volcano and just
start working that kind of yeah well
i'll add if it's if it's got a bunch of
different you know whistles and bells
i'll add like yes to that like other
cats for yeah yeah that's right yeah
like I put the topic of the joke and
then I just put the catchphrases of each
out of it yeah I don't know any other
kind of think that's how most comics I
know work right you know like I don't
really know anyone who I mean I didn't I
never really knew knew like comedy
joke-writing hell until I had to do a TV
set and write it all out oh we're glad
his hands and pray
actresses yeah they got to read it and
it's like like if you doing coning you
got to write the whole thing out uh or
you just give them a tape oh yeah watch
it and so they more people do it on tape
now but there was a time where they'd be
like no no we gotta read it all wow
crazy like haha yeah then you know when
I first started I didn't know I still
don't know how to write I just go up and
I just start doing stuff and if it works
alright you and you you go like me you
go kind of fast now so like writing out
five to seven minutes like like books
like an hour long even just you i'm
saying the jokes in my head writing it
out and you look at you go this is
terrible yeah none of this is a joke
yeah it's not a joke but it would be the
same thing if you read like a bill
birthing like only people you know it
would be like you know is like Jeselnik
stuff yeah is set him up now I'm down
that's classic joke right right right
that's classic joke riding it's
interesting too because on the last
Jaisal next special um which by the way
Anthony is one of my favorites ever and
and he's a lot like like I never know if
he's serious or not in the hall you know
sure yeah hey you want to do my podcast
no Ryan just walks why not yeah I've no
I will not be doing that and this walks
on you're like well he's joking right
yeah but in my mind I'm like what's my
podcast get to do for him like it's
gonna boost your career to get out of
him but and you know on his last special
he ended with that whole trouble use in
with comedy central yeah and I asked him
in the parking lot I said man that was
so [ __ ] electric the last 20 minutes
of your special is that gonna be your
new direction he was like I don't know
maybe you know yeah and then as I
watched his new stuff it's not his new
direction but his new stuff is so
[ __ ] great you know it's a little
more story to us both yeah right some
still got that story about being like uh
so drunk in England he couldn't like
speak or read the signs language that he
grew up with you know to me I our
language yeah thing planned I speak
English uh and uh
but in he'll still do you know dark just
one liners catcher he's one of the best
yeah he's always been one of my
favorites I remember it being in like
first time I got to know him was like
when I moved here like I don't know god
I'm with like 13 years ago or something
like that maybe like 12 years ago and
was like Kyle and I and like West
Hollywood's back on Kyle and I live
together and there's a show at one of
those gay bars like on Santa Monica oh
yeah and you you basically stood on the
bar and they project your face on a big
screen oh wow and you know every comics
kind of doing like course the bit about
it little jokes about well joke such a
dick on my screen right yeah get like hi
gays haha whatever yeah and like anthony
gets up there and the first thing he
goes is sup phaggots Wow huge laughs Wow
and they're just like oh [ __ ] you but it
was like yeah yeah no he said it like
smiling course and then he went into all
his evil [ __ ] it was like oh you're a
dick I get it yeah yeah yeah if anything
is like he's a dick on stage and off
stage he's not or even with you whatever
reason so God that made me laugh so hard
cuz just like [ __ ] man that's that's
that took some real balls yeah and that
was the reason it was funny cuz it's
ridiculous yeah no one that's here has
any any sort of animosity towards anyone
that's homosexual at all like being here
like what it was like oh you glorious
[ __ ] yeah he's a [ __ ] huh I know now
you and Kyle move out together yeah and
how struggling was that so you guys are
living in Chicago and one day what what
do you say let's get the [ __ ] out I was
just like I gotta get out of here and in
like the summer of two thousand two and
was like I mean I just I feel like a
hamster on the wheel yeah like I think
it's just time and you know people back
then would tell you everything from you
got to have a spec script you gotta have
a writer's packet everything don't go
out there without all kinds of junk and
rules just gay kills with these
invisible rules yeah you can't start
comedy when you're 44 yeah exactly I
just knew I was like no like like I know
like I can't I know I can't get myself
any excuses I'll just still be working
to the same bar still a waiter yeah and
I got out here I came out he
like a couple months before Kyle didn't
and Kyle came out and I was couch
surfing and he he while i was at work
found us an apartment like a two bedroom
wow great yeah and um uh uh was i think
it was it uh it's it's literally three
blocks from my girlfriend in my place
it's like it's no we don't know where
you live it looks feel it I me las pilas
oh yeah this big right people yeah I was
on dracaena and I cameras were at lola's
okay what was the rent like 850 it was
cuz back then yes felis Ronald yeah
probably was like 900 yeah for a two
bedroom I tell everyone when I just
moved here ladies or you just blew my
mind saying that cuz you're absolutely
yeah we were and we were scraping by oh
yeah cold like [ __ ] jobs we work you
know crap just world i was i first
started catering cuz that's you know
it's like a job i can get like that just
you know working these weddings and
stuff and then i was i was a PA just and
no like PA for a production company that
only the reality television oh yeah and
so and they would just like pay us [ __ ]
and no benefits and kyle was [ __ ] Kyle
uh that's why I can't believe people
watch that [ __ ] it's just say they're
worried about Chinese sweatshops when
we've got a sweatshop right here in
America reality shows yeah it's
basically the guys on the top for God
could you believe they're still watching
this [ __ ] we don't pay anything it's
like it yet it like that would but that
was it that was an awesome lesson
because when um Last Comic Standing came
along yeah I was like oh they can edit
it I've seen these people edit you to
look like anything oh yeah she can go on
that show my end of the evil ok I Dean
seems like a metal guy let's make him
the racist yeah and like at it something
you said in the wierdest way how do I
ruin your life ruiner whatever she's
wearing your life you know for ratings
yeah but Kyle was working cows working
at a like a musical instrument place no
[ __ ] he used to uh used to fill orders
for cake decorations over the phone yeah
and he also had to cold call people to
see if they needed more
cake decorations bits about that of like
what what is the thing you never need in
your life yeah more cake decoration it's
a car coming back notice that you get
the smiley faces yeah the stuffs just
seeing if you know [ __ ] right you
don't buy yeah uh and then he worked at
it as like a music instrument place that
would just seemed like absolute hell um
was there any competition between the
two you guys know we just like always
had this thing of um and then you know
the last job we had I got it first then
I got him a job there we were close
kappa captioners for the hearing
impaired and that was like that job was
awesome well where is that it's like Tim
Bank you just typed up the stuff not
just typed it like an advance so like
here's the law and order and you spend
like six hours captioning it like
editing yo start stop start write the
words put it in somewhere where doesn't
block someones face oh wow a lot of that
hahaha train sound right now laughter
and brackets yeah I'm caption [ __ ]
everything go ahead how about that ever
girls come on hunting shows is def i'm
georges hot wet breathing just a guy
looking good dear you know and then I
waited really gunshot and then just elk
falls over dead elk and lie sad that
that's Dutch job was great because they
give us time off and I could go out at
the time I was I started getting it like
a bunch of commercials oh yeah and so I
had like more money for us for like beer
and stuff and yeah and like so I had as
right team a's a little bit like i had a
little more success doing that and then
i got i got one went to montreal first
and i got like a manager first and stuff
but then kyle is like now like way
bigger than i am but it's like I always
just feel like like I'm always just like
go team yeah oh yeah cuz none of us none
of us have any kind of attitude about
like who's doing better and who's worse
it's just like look man I'm I'm paying
my rent and I'm I haven't had a real job
since 2008 yeah so that's [ __ ] the
wing it went exactly I feel like Kyle's
like my long-lost brother yeah like
secret oh yeah if you were like so weird
you're like yo we're cousins yeah like
yeah yeah yeah you are yeah you are no
way to tell us when we're on the same
showers
those guys related or what yeah you're
both tattooed I got that gravely yeah
man we can't have the same kind of ideas
like where you know we look at knife
kind of seen wearing the same kind of
music we love being max you know it's
all kinds of no mxp MMX yeah yeah no
Kyle so into BMX it's amazing we went we
went saw um Guns and Roses it's San
Diego their last show before they left
the state so great so good yeah so good
and he had just bananas seats courtesy
of the kid Jersey Kyle bought him for us
and her bottom called it we're gonna
sweat it when it's on the train and he
was just kidding into just like you know
the things people are doing with him now
it's better than any [ __ ] sports you
know I said I was like wow you know like
I didn't know that and I'm kind of it's
like so it's like we've known each other
so long and you know we don't hang out
as much as we used to you know back back
then but that's how it goes what you get
older and stuff yeah you're working and
then you both have girlfriends so it's
just like you come home and you don't
just go hey buddy pizza and beers fish
tacos well in Aisle was Kyle for a while
he was on the road so much maybe like
two three years ago like I never saw him
yeah and when he'd come home I knew for
a fact he wouldn't see any of his
friends you just sit in his apartment
it'd be like I don't want be around
anyone well you gotta do i press I think
that's a that's a it's an amazing thing
about comedy as much as you want to
start having success mm-hmm when it
starts to happen and and it's funny
because I played music for years and
it's way different because with music
you go on tour for like 3-4 months five
months maybe let's say year but then for
the next two years your home right in a
record and
and you know playing some local gigs and
stuff so you have some balance yeah but
with comedy it takes off and then you've
been poor so long you can't say no to
like well here's Weekend number 74 in a
row and you're like I told you know and
yeah but look at the offering like [ __ ]
uh-huh alright and you have you have
that fear that fear was like a bargain
yeah I'm just keep saying no I say no to
jobs they're gonna dry up mr. and but
it's like at the same time you've got to
have that balance thankfully Kyle does
now we're just like no no I need time
any time a home I have a relationship
now you know I need to preserve my
friendships with people and radio ver vo
also for Comedy Central so you gotta
check in your mind to go i can say no
those garbage gigs now even travels on
the road with like a recording device
yeah I know does it it's great crazy
yeah yeah now you guys wouldn't saw G&R
man how do you like that it was
incredible I i was knocked out by what a
good way agian our guy what kind of
music are you rock I I was I was some
rock I was really into hip-hop growing
up I sounds like a rap guy when I was a
kid like what early stuff NWA and stuff
are ya know I would've mid-90 stuff no
like the NWA and a great film ah ok yeah
it was great I really enjoyed it I did
too man i dare you that could have been
just complete cheese oh yeah it has been
a mess and i was part parts of it was I
was I remember those days and I was like
look man mm-hmm the line about we're
just telling the truth of the streets
don't feed me that [ __ ] he ranks I
didn't buy it back when I was 12 either
yeah big arrest it's like yes but you
guys got [ __ ] paid by saying the
filthiest [ __ ] yeah but also not like
garbage [ __ ] like even though it was fun
at the time 2 Live Crew horrible rappers
and let's just get paid n to be way
we're like you know I believed eazy-e
would murder three people on the way the
recording studio yeah believed it yeah I
was like this guy's killing people yeah
just like when you heard like you know
let's say kill them all metallic you
like these guys are maniac
Yeah right what these guys do to stab
people all the time yeah like it was
like when music had real edge almost
like they're in last little fete you
know right yes you definitely the devil
that's the tough action or I used to
tell a story while in saw mercyful fate
on don't break the oath album Wow and I
was i I was kind of like sitting up in
the balcony area Canada and I was a
little spooked yes cuz I was like hey
I'm pretty evil myself like I'm crazy
yeah but these people in here are a
little next level well we re in Portland
we had the punk rock scene yeah which
was very down and dirty and also you had
since Oregon his incredibly Caucasian
yeah you had a lot of [ __ ] hardcore
right wing skinheads yeah San Francisco
style to you know you had that punk
scene not the mabuhay yeah well that
we're terrifying I don't know were the
days of the pit where you'd be jumping
around and people would lift you up if
you fell wow this is amazing anymore and
no and never realize also guys who would
do like wall of death more like you know
or the [ __ ] fist around fish along a
guy that goes this is my favorite guy in
the pit he goes the opposite way just
basically the opposite of the pit like
yes take me out motherf er I me Tyga
it's like a a kamikaze pitter mhm this
is a you
it's just insane and we also had a this
group this group called the scars that
were skinheads committed against racism
Wow and they were like but but here's
the thing they were almost more violent
than and they would sharps the sharps I
figure they stand for it but they were
also like you know so against racism
which is this thing where they would
like attack you know all they want to do
is beat up a Nazi yeah I get that I got
the feeling I understand absolutely let
it out on some at the same time you're
being violent for violence sake don't
really want any social change it's just
wrong and it was just [ __ ] war in
some of these clubs where they'd be at
opposite ends and it wore two three
folks and you're like okay I can't be
between these guys know I'm in a [ __ ]
there's gonna be some knives your
pencils in your side like yeah I'm I'm
Anna I'm in like a windbreaker zip to
the neck yeah at the back of the room
like oh no I'm not I remember the wrong
show right now I saw one of the craziest
crowds of all time I went and saw Slayer
at the Sharks arena shark tank in san
jose and this is on god hates us all
tour yeah and I've never seen anything
like this the entire for was a pit and
what they did was they actually bought
Slayer shirts lit him on fire and ran
around in the pit with the shirts on
fire flannel shirts on fire and and I
was up and I was having like a side seat
and I was like this could be the most
radical thing I've ever witnessed this
is insane yeah and people just shirts
off on fire in the pit and it looks like
a Saxon invasion believable I remember
seeing the crowd at Lollapalooza to like
the old one oh yeah Anna to was great
was great oh I remember seeing I was up
on a hill it's like outside Seattle you
know this is the height of the grunge
thing so that I'd like Pearl Jam and
yeah Soundgarden yeah memory mm-hmm nice
kill us I mean looking down I saw
ministry playing that back this one
and it and like the crowd started moving
I was like oh this is what a medieval
war looks like yep from the top yeah
yeah yeah yeah I don't have knives and
axes and [ __ ] but it's like that's what
it looks like and the stage was all
bones ya ever that ministry yeah he's
yet bones hanging from his on his mic
stand like yeah like how Aerosmith has
scarves yeah he actual real shitty
killed earlier that day that [ __ ]
media with that with [ __ ] what's his
name just one fix it's got you know
monkey never dies tada burroughs william
s burroughs and it's just in there
monkey never dies yeah just like yeah
God that he was in that oh god burrows
man is also in that drugstore cowboy
remember the yes that's right and love
that and Matt Dillon runs into him in
that plays yeah man it's just [ __ ]
water what man music is just amazing
right like what are you listening to now
oh right right now it's all over the
place but i really i like the new de la
soul it was all a crown crowdfunded
album um and it's just it's so many left
turns it's so weird um but I have like a
ton of you know I'm like I've been
buying vinyl for a while yeah and and
let's see ah i was listening to cleaners
from Venus the other night it was like
you know you know a tease Britt pie yeah
uh Master puppets Oh through that on
radicular passed away last yeah alright
a man then I was dead it's just probably
one of my desert island albums free all
right you know it's tough to pick the
best Metallica it is stuff people hit me
all the time it's definitely never gonna
be kill them all for me never yeah but
it goes between lightning masters and
justice yeah it's really think I love
justice and I'll just I have a friend of
mine who's a musician who's like he
hates justice cuz the songs are great ah
but he says uh uh mix no no bit mix the
mix is like yeah he's all drums yeah
yeah and it cuz it's because the drummer
did it yeah the drummer was like no more
drums I never you know what's what it's
like I never noticed that me too i
played music and i recorded records all
my life and i think that like you're
missing the
whole point of a record if you sit down
like people hated st. anger cuz they're
like no guitar solos and and [ __ ] and
then they hated the next one cuz Oh Lars
his snare sounds horrible okay who's
even listening to that I never put it on
to go well I don't know about this yeah
man I put it on four or five on my
stereo it's [ __ ] rockin and are the
songs good or not yeah well I care about
it's like how ac/dc had no guitar solos
but they had like a bagpipe solo yeah
now let's have a bagpipe one though yes
but it's their amazing songs it gives a
[ __ ] yeah and it's just at the end of
the day and and justice for all is just
such a [ __ ] like a statement man yeah
no one was doing that it was just prog
metal mm-hmm you're like these songs are
like eight nine minutes yeah they're
about the most insane [ __ ] ever oh it's
like when you hear when you hear
something like that and you haven't
heard anything like it before like which
which I hadn't not really no uh like the
first time you hear blackened like
what's going on like you have that thing
even as a someone who has no
musicianship whatsoever not really like
these guys are like classical musicians
and they are oh yeah they really are
absolutely no same is like Sammy's like
puppets is starting a battered oh [ __ ]
you know yeah just like oh I'm I'm it i
made a kook classical acoustic guitar
yeah concert in yeah oh my god yeah yeah
you don't make them until I can come to
the wall
you know just like I you know I think
head field is definitely one of the top
five guys of all time it's just I never
seen a guy I mean I just recently got
this book it's a coffee table book the
30 years of Master of Puppets oh you got
to see it it's at my house and it's a
it's a huge coffee table book and they
sold it about a month ago through their
website it opens with the with the bus
crash with ku F to show where they were
and then it goes into this fool
pictorial and notes and everything of
the making of this record and there's
all these handwritten lyrics there and
as if you're looking at the handwritten
lyrics to think you know and I love when
people say like you know he's only like
20 to what he wrote that it's like
that's when everybody writes their
masterpiece yeah I do yeah it's
different with comedy I always tell
people with comedy yeah people who write
their masterpieces till twenty years
later yeah but with rock it's totally
the opposite you know later you you feel
like you get older you overthink it yeah
so many more experiences you've got it
kind of has to be like a lily a gang
little simple and maybe a little dumb
yeah you know yep where it's just like
things just land yeah but I looked at
his lyrics you know and and and and i
think i remember when i was 22 and i was
right and like you know like i'm looking
at his lyrics go like how do you even
come up with this [ __ ] I know he's
reading a lot of books he was about war
and and of course he's gone through
stuff with you know drugs and everything
like that but just the way he does it
he's not like all hitting the streets
look for heroin shoot it in my arm guys
that I don't know yeah it's all this
[ __ ] intricate stuff you know a
master of puppets you know feel like to
rock culture and drug cultures is just
like metaphors and slang you have nobody
ago no one has ever liked hey guys when
I get some heroin after the show yeah
there's always some that hold yeah yeah
you know and if that can go for anything
that could be you know you reference
your motorcycle well like I don't know
the [ __ ] he's talking about yeah well
plan a guy on here
mark Ford from the black resin he called
cocaine chilly weather which was the
most genius to me that's the genius term
everybody came up to his like hey man
you know anybody that's kind of it all
chili with her dude that's okay then I i
SAT and tried to name a mall you know I
a toot bumpy road colombo marching
powder marching powder ah blow ah but
you know booger sugar sugar sugar all
those you know tweak whatever yeah it
was so many and all of them he had come
up with the top one yeah it's a great
chilly weather that's so like like
Capote like George Clinton was saying
that Sly Stone he spoke entirely in
metaphors Wow so like people were just
he's like I've never heard someone use
slang better than that in my whole life
god that's a like number one soul
brother could just you just you know
yeah you around like record executives
like to [ __ ] is this guy talking about
why it's so great anything I just
tweeted a video of them sign of Family
Stone playing uh uh Midnight Special oh
yeah from like 75 or whatever is
mind-boggling yeah I have like six their
albums oh they're all different yeah
they're all amazing next level [ __ ] man
yeah you know I mean to watch them play
that [ __ ] there live I just sit there
and go this is incredible yeah he's just
up there men and his finesse on the
guitar and his outfit and [ __ ] is just
like you know if they want make that
stat you're happy around no why you know
and he's just touching the guitar it's
like bout won't work now yeah killer man
Wow yeah and and like even someone who
like a modern musician like D'Angelo oh
yeah who is awesome he amazing but he
was like a sly a family stone band is my
favorite band yeah to this day yeah of
anyone like he's like that cuz he he can
name all the musicians yeah and it was
like Bennett on it was like United
Nations of people you had a white guy
and it
yeah and I mean I'm looking at and
you're just like look at the unity going
on here and then as a no you know
weren't into yeah oh definitely yeah
there's white guys like a [ __ ] man
there's a white guy doing yeah every
white person be like I hate this music
yeah you know and it's so funny that
we're still talking about race issues
right now yeah and you think he's up
there he's singing about race issues
he's got a multicultural band and here
we are 2016-17 coming up cuz and it's
just freaking unbeliev 90 away it's
weird I was just in the Bible Belt well
with burr doing shows and and it's just
like you think it like people you're
like well they're not gonna think like
that anymore they got the internet and
stuff now right no no wow the Internet's
made it worse related worse man yes
they're just like the actually one guy
was saying the internet with actually
what the devil was he's like a it's just
a it's just opening it up Satan right
there and it's just like wow yeah yeah I
got no time for that mm-hmm I really
don't i'm only God could be here only
five more years and something that the
devil has certain things you can kind of
you look at and use usefully yeah you
know I mean they're not give it up a
part of yourself or something she's like
there's a lot of helpful I can show my
cell phone up and I was like Satan
junior right here this is this is ball
another phone is Memphis top yeah these
are lower level team work for Lucy yeah
yeah yeah meanwhile he had one in his
hand yeah I mean hey Josh yeah [ __ ] what
do you what do you got coming up uh
let's see just doing I got I got a pilot
I did for amazon it's gonna be coming
out with Ben Schwartz and I that's and
it's got like Rory Scovel a bunch of
great people that that's probably coming
to the great thing about Amazon is they
put their pilots up oh yeah that goes
here and armor right right like yeah um
Marilyn rice cub I had one up last year
yeah and if the people like it they make
it yeah wait its a mix right you don't
mean they they might also be like we
still like this one let's do it you know
it's supposedly it'll be up by December
uh and then other than that I got a
Netflix special called big dumb animal
that people can check out a vinyl uh
yeah I vinyl for all my specials yeah I
saw you I see your vinyl every time at
San Jose improvident I pictured of it
ever all right on man I Love You Man you
too buddy thanks for going to go give
him your uh your twitter i'm on at
Braunger br a un ger yeah and Matt
Braunger calm for any my shows come back
again I would love to all right loves it
thank you so much and I'll see you at
the story yet the store this week not
this week but I'm coming back next week
I'll give my avails right on thanks for
tuning in guys phone and keep keep
pardon thanks guys candles lit that's
great awesome